these days many different types of
fields or I'll say most of the life
sciences Fields definitely have the
integration of bioinformatics and it's
very important for you to understand to
learn what bioinformatics is all about
to have a understanding or I'll say
fundamental basic understanding of
bioinformatics then we have a module on
bytes and molecules it's very important
for students to understand that all the
concepts they are learning how they
could be applied to different resource
specialization areas now these resource
specialization areas uh feels like
oncology infectious diseases
neurosciences metabolic disorders or
agriculture where you can apply the
specific type of foric analysis
expertise that you will gain next comes
identifying a specific field that you
want to work on with so you identify a
specialized omx field that you want to
learn how the analysis is performed and
then after gaining an understanding of
the analysis workflow you learn how
different tools or softwares could be
used the first thing comes learning art
or python that's a must to know uh
computering language these days to be
able to perform the analysis with
different types of omix data and then
comes the knowledge of different tools
even databases these days have different
tools integrated inside them that you
can leverage to extract the data perform
the analysis you have these different
tools databases and softwares that you
need to learn how you you can analyze
the data that is lying there in those
gold mins I'll say or I'll say data mins
that have this data that still needs to
be analyzed to interpret biological
insights out of it so three resources is
covering uh the tools are python uh
databases tools and softwares that are
available openly that you can learn and
leverage for analysis of your omix data
all right so training aspect is clear if
there are any questions from what I have
just said you can please put your
questions in the chat the moment I take
a pause I'll go through the questions
and help you um understand after
training comes the resource
specialization tracks now most of you as
students you reach out to us and you
tell us that you want to work on a
desertation project as January commences
most of you have to start with your
desertation now the question comes uh
that once you have your training
completed with a specific omix field
what type of research question you want
to work on with do you want to work with
uh specific metabolic disorder like
diabetes it could be or a specific type
of of cancer or in the field of
Agriculture or you want to understand
how the uh omx data looks like in
astronauts maybe all right or do you
want to understand how neurosciences or
neurod developmental or neuro
degenerative disorders work so there are
different fields that you can uh get a
hold of there are different fields for
which you have different omic data
present learn a specific type of
analysis pick up a field and we are good
to begin with the research project how
do you do that the next step is once you
have the track finalized once you have
the field finalized after that you have
to review literature come up with a
research proposal a research question
that you want to work on and start your
journey we at omix logic uh would be
there with you for each and every step
to train you to uh come up with your
research question and then start your
research Journey once you have uh
completed the step that the the step
that I just mentioned and have your
research question finalized that's when
your program commences now how how does
the program work the program works in a
way where once your research Journey
commences the mentor guides you on what
work or what steps uh should be included
in your research next so in the training
you'll get the access to the enters
lectures those are recorded lectures
that you go through and learn from the
tbio info platform is uh is an automated
uh pipeline uh generated platform that
I'll just take you through where all you
need to do is just upload your data
perform the analysis get the results
interpret them and you're good to put
your report together all right so
students when they have to work on
projects in a short time period the
pipelines on the tbio info platform are
really helpful to them because uh they
help them complete their analysis
quickly and also those who require High
Computing systems but do not have the
facilities with them the platform would
help them for the same which surise the
problem next we'll take you through RN
python collabs uh that I mentioned and
the courses that are there on the omix
logic learn portal that I'll take you
through today would assess to you get
the expertise for a specific omix
analysis and once you complete your
research work then comes your reporting
publication you may also get a
recommendation from US based on your uh
research work and we'll also guide you
or help you in a research proposal
writing for further applications after
completing a research project some
students come up and say that they want
to apply for a PhD program or they want
to apply for a specific faculty program
uh or a a job position maybe but they
have to submit a proposal there or they
want a recommendation so uh so our
assistance would be there for you at
each and every step all right so that
was all about the structure what's
included and how we go about the entire
research fellowship program